bonsoir et bienvenue pour le cette suite
un cadre un peu particulier pour débuter
cette émission nous ne sommes pas sur le
plateau à guyancourt nous sommes sur le
quai de la gare de trappes en pleine
nuit dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi
des travailleurs de nuit sont en train
de travailler à la rénovation de cette
gare nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
pour débuter cette édition
on va donc parler de ce chantier qui se
déroulent du côté de trappes durant la
nuit avec l'un des responsables leonel
del aguila bonsoir merci de nous
accueillir sur votre chantier
parce que là c'est une nuit où vous
allez encore travailler comme pendant
deux semaines en fait pendant deux
semaines le soir la nuit vous travaillez
c'est ça vous intervenez tout à fait et
ça consiste en quoi ces interventions de
nuit sur sept sur sept gares alors vous
comme vous avez pu le voir tout à
l'heure on va poser des auvents cette
gare a fait l'objet de grands travaux de
rénovation il ya une partie des travaux
qui nécessitent la mise en place de au
vent et de pièces métalliques qui se
trouve à proximité immédiate de la
caténaire qui alimentait à 1500 vols et
à proximité immédiate des circulations
ferroviaires dont ces opérations ne peut
pas les faire en journée pour la simple
et bonne raison qu'il ya un risque
ferroviaire et pour nos clients
donc on est obligé d'intervenir la nuit
les premières personnes qui
interviennent ce sont les personnels
sncf on pourra le voir tout à l'heure on
a quelqu'un qui va prendre les
procédures de sécurité c'est à dire qui
va dans un premier temps s'assurer qu'il
n'ya plus trafic ferroviaire sur cette
voie là cette voie là c'est à dire qu'il
ya un échange des pêches en échange d'un
primé et une fois qu on a l'assurance
qu'il n'y a plus aucun train on va
pouvoir couper la caténaire la caténaire
qui alimentent notre 1 c'est à dire à
quelqu'un ou dans lequel les 1500 watts
et m classe et nrc le câble électrique
ciel canadien tous et avec tout ça voilà
et assuré qu'il n'ya plus de courant
électrique et quand il n'y aura plus
courant électrique on disposera de ce2
autorisation écrite que l'on remettra à
l'entreprise et elle pourra commencer
ses travaux de montage la structure et
pousse à l'âge et à la poignée pour
ouvrir le sectionneur quant aux ça
permet de couper le courant à partir de
cet appareil que la couche d'ozone la
presse a raconté le plus rapide de la
procédure
c'est un canal spécial sourire
alors là vous intervenez ce soir ou
demain matin les changements vont être
visible tout de suite pour les usagers
de la gare
et bien pas tout de suite encore si vous
voulez ce soir on va pouvoir faire on va
monter encore des pièces alors celui qui
viendraient tous les jours ils verraient
bien ils ont fait ça s'est tenue ils ont
fait ça ce soir on va commencer à monter
les pièces les plus proches de la
caténaire celles qui sont les plus
dangereuses et la semaine prochaine on
commencera à mettre le toit là ça
commence à être visible
ils ont fini de poser les consoles en
fait du côté qu'est ce qui était plus
proche des caténaires s'il faut pas
rentrer dans le périmètre des trois
mètres pour éviter justement un arc
électrique
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a demandé la
coupure caténaires donc là il continue
de poser les consoles ensuite ils vont
continuer à poser les rives la
couverture et c'était raconte alors
peut-être pas tout dans la nuit parce
qu'effectivement la coupure est très
très petit donc après ils ont encore
calculations prochaine pour terminer
toutes ces parties là nous allons donc
laisser ces travailleurs de nuit pour
suivre le travail ici à trappes de
rénovation de la gare et on va se rendre
à guyancourt sur le plateau du 7 8 pour
faire le point comme chaque soir sur
l'actualité locale